17 мільярдів гривень сама відчуваю джед
україни мого трюми адже ти private а
потім з 1200 даруєш компанії ще плану
з ставка ти 3 тену малаві дату провід не
руки до кінця руку у team нас клаусі
міністр економіку україни кутку supra
перенесено невелику приватизацію на
доступний рік експерти попереком факт на
високим інтересом збоку інвесторів то
включенням українських олігархів
сам міністр не за парою чого юна вниз
конфлікту з олігархами вона віктор
минуванні по я з нею і нашим обожненням
не просто про дати pride спадкоємство
адже дати їх у добрі руки
люди люди ще ближче не до влади типу
передню мої будні там менеджмент річки
слідуєте сир і 10 року в таких чіпів
50 ракет сидіти компанії ви зміг туди
криючої зараженої компанії ви зміг то
вал це будуть ви зможуть їм там у c-3po
при зрозуміти лише лихом приватизації виду
тец і вкривати не руки відомого
приватної владних і всю та й завжди
і на вище в Україні карраччі кіру і
зробимо дзвінок за факт підприємствами
це факт
міністр не приходиш чашу до я прийду 7
іноземних інвесторів при спробі їх нині
значить олег шині spi в руку тому
поважайте мінекономіки батько доступного
руку трохи економічне зрощення заповнюючи
глава відомства
списку потенційних інвесторів курять
винахідливо що вони українських олігархів
вони тим більше інвесторів з Росії
мого очевидного чому я до номінації
очевидно чому російські на сторони
вими брат і долею приватизації знову
україні
агресії очевидно агресія тут шість
тисяч людей за різьблених людей загинули
відомі російські інвестори та
чи українського арка так і зможе взяти і
вчитися привіт а потім через підставні
фірми
вона цінна головне поважати експерти
завдання номер один пізно державу
квіткових підприємств тобто і рівний
корупції ціни функція державою позики
туса економіка функція держави
займатися
ну прямо суті ванної з ким економічним
інтересами як і спить принца функція
центровий кабель макро економічно
україни в таких після галльських он іди
знову і карстові цистит принц для того
щоб фінансово то політичні проекти та
партій і чим шви чим з'явиться з рухаємось
цим гарним
стратегічний чекаєш компанії і кік і
обіймаючи на мир і правоту за висновок та
кабмін плану та прикро ти в один holding
a управлінням передати іноземним
менеджером для by схованості то про
зарости